hello that reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we are gonna watch a
top reward to your video requests from
loyal patronage act Andrew hey it's top
10 best movie villains of the decade I
said thank god you're requesting this
cuz I don't want to make my own list
I just want to riff on someone else's
opinion yes it's not really opinions
this is objective this is very objective
oh yeah watch Mojo's let's check it out
they're undeniably bad but they sure are
good at it hey guys it's TV with watch
mojo hi Phoebe our picks for the top 10
movie villains of the decade
Steppenwolf it has to be a 20-19 you
will see human and monster villains here
but no animated ones let's get to it
okay if you like what you're hearing be
sure to check out the full song at the
link below what is this sound' mojo
thing
and dependent artists we gonna promote
their stuff on there I don't know
someone has to request one for us to
find out
the only way we do anything
[Music]
number ten Joker Arthur Fleck Joker meow
can you introduce me as Joe could you
put her miss ten what the hell with this
film he proved that he doesn't need
Batman to maintain that status though
2019 s Joker had its detractors few
critics could find fault with Joaquin
Phoenix's brilliant performance you
listen dear now a mental illness is a
tough subject to tackle especially when
the character in question is supposed to
be a villain there's always a fear of
demonizing mental illness with a little
boy the Phoenix and director Todd
Phillips did a solid job wait mental
illness is a real thing and not made up
in this movie like a cold for your life
just take a pill number nine nominated
for an Academy Award like Joaquin
Phoenix Leonardo DiCaprio is considered
among the most talented actors of his
generation who else could take a role
like Jordan Belfort and simultaneously
make him both reprehensible and so
magnetically charming as DiCaprio had
already proven in your earlier however
he's every bit as capable of turning off
that charm
if you lift those palms off that
tabletop both barrels that start off
playing against type as 19th century
slave owner Calvin Candie DiCaprio
wholly commits to the sadistic
hate-filled and thoroughly repulsive
villain his bigotry and racism know no
bounds but as detestable as candy is
the manner swagger and quirks with which
DiCaprio and abused the character makes
him the sort of villain we love to hate
the fact that Leo didn't get an Oscar
nomination for this scene-stealing
performance is baffling you do not have
anything to drink can I get you a tasty
refreshment yes no that would be on the
bar number eight
Lord Voldemort Harry Potter and the
Deathly Hallows Part 2 before he was
brought to the big screen Baltimore had
already been established as one of the
greatest villains in modern literature
so dark as such the risk of the
live-action interpretation of the
character falling short of fan
expectations was incredibly and JK
Rowling support strands right off of the
page and onto the screen in the final
installment of this epic series finds
holds nothing back fully inhabiting the
role it's Baltimore tis cruel and
imposing there's danger behind every
word he delivers an inherent volatility
that's terrifying to behold I will say
really fun does not get enough credit
for bringing Baltimore's alive and yet
he's also charismatic in a way that
makes you understand how he seduced so
many to his side number seven Erik kill
monger Seaton's black panther no oh it's
not the first time we've said it but the
MCU
for all its strengths has really
struggled to bring compelling villains
to the big screen would kill monger
however they absolutely hit it out of
the park Black Panther was the first
comic book superhero movie to be
nominated for best picture at the
Academy Awards oh please expertly by
Michael B Jordan kill monger is a fully
fleshed out villain who
site his lethal methods has relatable
and sympathetic motivations you will
destroy the world Makana included the
world is everything away from me he's a
character with real emotional depth and
a powerful backstory and when you add
that to his physicality you've got to do
and worthy of our hero in every regard
just bury me in the ocean
well my ancestors that jump on ships
they knew was better than box number six
Terence Fletcher whiplash 2014 most of
the villains we've discussed up until
this point have been notably largest
movie as may be permanently scared of
Jacob chicken he's the sort of
antagonist that any one of us could
encounter in our own academic or
professional careers as Fletcher JK
Simmons plays a master emotional
manipulator preying on the vulnerability
and ambitions of his students on his
quest for musical perfection he's cruel
and violent and yet he's fundamentally
human and not with that sentiment or
honor
like so many real-world villains he
doesn't see himself as one prick number
5 Amy Elliott Dunne gone girl there are
some spoilers have you seen this tired
trope and often serves as a lazy
stand-in for actual character
development
Amy checks a lot of the boxes
traditionally as so smart the text which
is anything but two-dimensional I can
say that despite all the mystery
initially surrounding Amy's
disappearance this film takes us deep
inside her mind inviting us to
understand what makes this character
she is phenomenal god I am so sick of
hearing that brazen unreliable narrator
as he here tossed everywhere now
literary technique Amy is a villain
worthy of a greater hero than she ever
faced it I just want to accept the fact
that that is what happened and then not
open up theories anymore
to the unreliable narrator think just
let me accept it
picture this you meet the girl of your
dreams and everything seems to be going
great after a few months she asks you to
meet her parents and you go along with
it the [ __ ] is this you know
the Armitage family is deeply racist
take the term manipulative to sickening
new heights and you know I thought
Daniel Kaluga was the bad guy that's
right was keeping all these white people
there just your average family next door
it poses open-minded and progressive
cruelest and most selfish of impulses
[Music]
it's a reflection of our own mortality
born we breathe we die
number three it's penny wise to dancing
clown
first off is so much better okay
it is a shapeshifter and a reality
manipulator who knows how to appeal to
the good-natured sympathies of children
so that he can eat them but only after
seasoning their meat with fear we never
dreamed that someone could hold a candle
to Tim Curry steak on the titular terror
but bill skarsgård has turned in the
performance of a lifetime to make a
whole new generation of cinema goers
terrified of this monstrous villain the
horror genre isn't short on horrific
creatures but with his unique quirks and
the clear joy he takes in his work
Pennywise is cut from a different cloth
you have been Thanos is numero uno kylo
Ren this Star Wars sequel trilogy
no one will ever talk Darth Vader and
you've got me opinions about this one
man I'll go blisters on Fifi Ben solo
feels like Vader's internal struggle
between the dark and light sides of the
force personified he's a slave to his
emotions both positive and negative in
many ways he feels like the sort of
complex tortured character that George
Lucas was trying to craft with Anakin
Skywalker and the prequels this one I
thought we stumbled on a video where we
finally don't have to talk about Star
Wars
well that's no no let's see some
honorable mentions and watch this again
dancy we are the last two rats we can
either eat each other
number one kathleen kennedy oniy to
everyone else
oh yeah but did he wipe out 50% of the
world I don't think so a little bit yeah
hi here like 46 honorable gotta see the
Paddington Holmes begins yeah no one's
why doesn't she be talked about him all
this hospital bus no really obsess
you're on your phone make sure you go
into your settings and switch on
notifications number one Thanos
Avengers infinity war and Avengers and
he I would say infinity that post
credits he firmly believes that his
devastating methods are entirely
justifiable I think thatís earns it he's
the hero of his own story Thanos is a
formidable physical threat but his
greatest strength is his unflinching
resolve a complex and charismatic
villain Samus raised the bar in multiple
ways the MCU is the most ambitious world
building ever seen in film and after a
looming over it for years Thanos shook
this universe to its core who will
this universe down to its last sure he
really is gonna live up to the hype I
hate them all you're wrong
what about apocalypse yeah what about
the New Mutants I would say Michael
Fassbender from which film shame
Assassin's Creed
oh yeah the shame is development shame
shame is the villain
I would say Michael Fassbender from 12
years of slave I thought he was ruthless
and terrifying pure sadistic but I guess
so I had a room for one racist slave
owner and that was the Caprio handy and
ha Django Unchained who was great and I
think will forever be hail this one is
the biggest
Oscar snubs of all time what about Jake
Gyllenhaal from Nightcrawler
who that yeah that's great and he's the
protagonist of the film yeah but I guess
they only have room for one antihero
Arthur flex and Joker that's right
that's the most you can do not that
they're Patrick's I feel like Arthur
Fleck is is a great one but he's too
much of the protagonists of the film to
me and he's not really painted as a
villain for a villain most of it the
villain seems to be a lot of
circumstance and a lot of outside
factors especially cuz everyone's kind
of an [ __ ] to him in that movie yeah
neglect rudeness and a lack of
consideration one of the best anti
heroes of the decade put Nightcrawler he
is straight up the village yeah yeah get
away from him sidekick guy Calvin can't
I think is a wonderful performance and
definitely an Oscar stub I did find
Michael FAAST fenders to be a
significantly more ruthless as you see
12 years a slave
oh yeah oh yeah watch it all time gonna
repeat yeah I know some people who watch
it while I met her no it's just playing
in the back wash myself in our nation's
shameful history keep myself down to
earth DiCaprio he's intense and scared
he's like fun and entertaining to watch
but he's not altogether that's smart
it's Sam Jackson who has to point out
for him like you know they're playing
you right it's like damn yeah but well
yeah but
just makes him that much less he's it's
shown throughout the movie that he's not
as cultured as he lets on he's kind of a
brat so in that way I mean those are
still icky qualities but I do understand
because I think like they're both ugly
characters but there's a certain
harshness that is never alleviated by
humor to Michael Fassbender in 12 years
of slave yeah I could see why you would
want to swap them out although exactly
that Leo role that Calvin Candie is
pretty pretty iconic it's it isn't it
yeah no it's definitely left more of a
staple in the zeitgeist I'm just saying
man if you have a slave owner or evil
category that's right
why not honorable mention at least man
what the hell oh call me by your name
homophobia
that's a villain even still today sorry
to bother you
capitalist you know ray Fiennes is
Voldemort is not talked about enough I
think that's the issue you run into
sometimes when you play a an iconic
villain doused in makeup or visual
effects like Thanos both of those had
such a mantle to uphold
Voldemort he-who-must-not-be-named them
one of the most iconic villains from
literature being brought to the big
screen teased and then you know he
doesn't come in a full formation until
what is it Goblet of Fire when you see
him actually walking around the
culmination film of Harry Potter and
Deathly Hallows part-2 and then of
course fan OHS with Josh Brolin and body
in that role both of those have so much
hype so much of anticipation for when
they're finally gonna be taking center
stage as the villain in the in the
movies and I think they both really
delivering and ray Fiennes especially I
think does not get enough like Voldemort
is so remembered and both immortals have
been so edified throughout the series
that are kind of just except yeah
Baltimore yeah instead of like pretty
finds really delivered on that it
doesn't and I don't think he gets enough
credit for that but as long as we have a
ray Fiennes category I mean what about
Harry from in Bruges I mean that's a
villain with convictions and integrity
just think that as long as we have a
refined slot we should be able to switch
him out you know are you mocking me no
what are you talking about okay I was
misled JK Simmons with whiplash it's
weird because
angry top dog controlling authoritative
figure
was something we had seen him do with
Jay jonah Jameson and it's funny it's
hilarious and then he does like a very
realistic rendition of the guy who's
yelling and belittling people like a
teaching horror experience and he is so
scary in it and so believable he won the
Oscar for that right he's he's so
believable in it that I just M would be
so scared to meet the guy that's how
good he is in that movie that's what
he's like in the booth during those mmm
commercial tapings yelling at the red
M&M like is that cartoonish enough you
could just literally show people like
that's the first scene when he loses his
[ __ ] I'm miles teller not quite my tempo
you know that belittling him how it
ramps up from like calm it's okay to
like the most horrifying a beauty like
he's thrown a cymbal at em one like
Olivia hadn't seen whiplash I'm like oh
you just show you this once and she was
like oh my god even just so mean
flashing back now he's something special
in that movie and a horrible kind of way
I'm sorry gone girl got ruined for you
did you know that yeah it's been ruined
for me already I mean actually looking
at this video I didn't really pick up
the context for what the spoilers were
supposed to be even though I know what
they're supposed to be I think Gangrel
did not succeed as much as it could have
because of the fact that you can't
reveal this and it because this is
actually like a little deeper for you
like halfway through when you learn this
yeah and in the trailers the whole thing
they're building up is what kidnapped
the wife yeah she's been missing is she
killed and people think Ben Affleck the
husband did it and then halfway through
you find out that she hasn't done all
this recession she's kidnapped herself
yeah and she's amazing in the movie when
I saw the trailer for him like look
school was a good David Fincher movie I
don't really know what to expect and
then when they introduced this plotline
it's not just some final twist it's a
part of the whole movie
like it is a major central focus once
it's implemented in the film and she
killed it I'm really happy she's on this
list I'm very very happy she's on this
list cuz yeah she made a quite an
impression
mhm Rosamund Pike named penny wise you
have coarse horse it's like the famous
Scott for horror yeah decade he's the
biggest horror phenomenon right now
and it's sure though he he did something
that usually doesn't work because Tim
Curry was so iconic in that role and
such a specific voice and mannerisms to
go from aiya Georgie Georgie Georgie to
go right up here like the complete
opposite in terms of delivery voice
cadence and to still be terrifying to do
the complete flip brilliant because
normally that wouldn't work yeah it's
really hard to replace something that is
thrusted by an actor specifically you
know yeah yeah they did manage to catch
lightning in a bottle twice with that
character it seems like and I wonder
whose choice that was to do it that way
if it was the directors or if it was a
scarf skarsgård cary fukunaga and the
Armitage family I was I was kind of
surprised that they went for that angle
it was cool to get like an ensemble
villain I think the us ones were better
the more I think that tethered is more
specific of a villain to include the
family from get out I think is
interesting because to me suggests
something a bit more insidious like I
feel like the tethered are a more freaky
in-your-face kind of villain where the
Armitage family hides in plain sight
it's like they said like to the outside
world there's normal affable liberal
family yeah you know you made a very
point when you first meet them they were
very charming family and very funny I
guess it's the brother and it pulls it
out for me yeah I'm like he wasn't
really much but everyone else in the
family especially what's-her-name Rose
especially uh is great she's amazing
she's the one we're like you know the
rest of the family's messed up but you
are starting to wonder the whole film
she on this she had on this I don't know
if he's known the whole bit with the
keys they came from ekitoku she's not
get out together really god damn it
happy ending Kyle okay
and welcome this video I can't go into
spoilers because it's not warranted but
this video I believe did come out before
the rise of Skywalker had to have
because as filming this it comes up
today that's true yeah came out a couple
days ago well I guess he has made a
staple in culture and is a conic
character ultimately I personally
wouldn't have put him on this list while
I find Adam driver to be one of the best
things out of that whole trilogy I
thought the last Jedi set him up to
potentially be one of the best villains
of all time
I'll leave it at that yeah I wonder how
this will all age but especially given
the completion I am interested as to how
people will feel about the placement on
this list would you feel better if it
was lower if it wasn't the second one oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah I think I think so
I mean yeah there's no denying the
iconography of the character but at the
same time like the people really I feel
like people were pretty split on him and
force awakens oh yeah and then last Jedi
was people like editors like the best
one know he's always under someone else
I think this one made the last Jedi is
the special like in the first one it
kind of feels like discount Vader I
never really felt like kylo did things
that were have you Lee despicable well I
mean yeah he killed honk they killed his
own dad but it wasn't like he was clever
manipulator master of things it's like
yeah you know there's a whole legal room
this whole argument to be out of here
but if he is I feel like he should have
been a little bit higher is it yeah
because there's always a pool with the
guy like is he gonna be good is he gonna
be that ultimately if you're gonna put
him on this list for the trilogy you
should wait til rise this guy Walker yes
but I know people will definitely
disagree because I think Adam driver is
one of the best out of the whole trilogy
I've been in terms a villain of the
decade I'm not sure I give it there
my thoughts on that little change he's
ultimately an antihero whatever yeah
overall it's pretty positive pretty
solid list I'd say I think this did a
really good job I might say like Koba
from dawn of the Planet of the Apes oh
he was a great villain mmm it's a
wonderful gun you really I felt he had a
lot of pathos that care I felt sorry for
him but also found a very threatening
and menacing at the same time you
wouldn't get with Caesar's program took
matters into his own hands war for the
caesars program all right guys what you
think of this list leave a comment down
below what villains would you have
wanted to add on here subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell make sure to subscribe to
watchmojo.com 'then dude do you go
you're supposed to be the expert in
surviving snowpocalypse is that's that's
embarrassing yeah yeah Andrew Hayes sent
us a documentary he made with some
friends a couple years ago is really
informative it helps you survive in a
snowpocalypse and andrew is the host of
the video so I'm a little disappointed I
hope you at least warrior bomber Jackies
you don't want to catch a cold Andrew I
hope you have a great Christmas also I
just want to say if your mom's watching
this that mrs. Hayes I do
and if your dad's watching this I locked
myself out of my car could you come and
help me with that thank you yeah